[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right hey everybody welcome back to
eight news now i'm monica jackson and it
is time for mondays with monica and
today we're talking about vaping i know
you guys have been seeing the
commercials
you've seen all the stories about it i
wonder if you know how very dangerous
this really is and it touched a
personal spot with me because i had a
grandmother who passed away as a result
of lung cancer
and as the vaccine rolls out kids may be
going back to school some might be doing
that hybrid thing so
i wanted to bring it back around because
it's very important dr jennifer pearson
is joining us this morning
thank you so much for being here uh dr
pearson tell us about
uh the nevada tobacco prevention
coalition and how you guys are tackling
all of this
yeah thank you for having me so the
nevada tobacco prevention coalition or
ntpc it's a collaborative effort between
organizations and individuals that work
in public health
in government medics medicine and
education
and our goal is to ultimately eliminate
the death and disease due to tobacco use
and second-hand smoke exposure in nevada
people think that this is a solved
problem but
we still have more than 400 000 people a
year in the united states dying from
tobacco use
it's primarily cigarette smoking but
we're starting to
see some concerning things happening
with vaping and e-cigarette use among
teens in 2019
high school students in nevada 22.5
percent of them reported vaping in the
last month
and that is very concerning even though
vaping is less harmful than smoking
cigarettes
and many adult smokers have found
e-cigarettes helpful in quitting smoking
saying something that's less harmful
than smoking is insane a lot because it
is by far the most harmful thing you can
do for your body
yeah and and here's what makes me mad dr
pearson
are there any laws in place any
legislation going through the pipeline
right now
to um get on top of these companies that
are peddling this stuff to kids
because it seems like somebody needs to
be held accountable
yeah absolutely i would say that the
main kind of action in that area
is that people are starting to sue
companies so you know companies often
say well that's not what we meant to do
right but and i can't speak to what they
meant to do because i can't read their
minds but
the reality is is that these companies
designed manufactured and marketed a
harmful
addictive product that nearly a quarter
of nevada's high school students have
used recently yeah and it is their
responsibility
to make sure that adolescents don't use
their products and so we're starting to
see people sue
companies like jewel it's a big one that
people hear about there's a
gigantic lawsuit of 786 people or
something like that happening right now
just starting to get going and i think
that's gonna we're gonna see some
some movement on that let's talk about
the top three things
the effects of this vaping because as i
was reading uh your information it was
just disgusting to me
what happens to a kid as they're
starting this horrible habit
give me the first one well sure
so you know vaping
nicotine among youth does open up a
bunch of concerns
so vaping
exposure during adolescence can affect
their brains it can affect how their
brains
are able to kind of process information
it can control how they can in the
future
um make uh decisions executive function
etc we're not a hundred percent sure on
the science on that quite yet but
even if it's biologically plausible and
therefore i think it's a
very good reason to avoid nicotine use
in adolescence
here's the one that really stuck with me
dr pearson it just grossed me out
chemical burns in the lungs of vapors
from nicotine and thc resemble the
damage
that was seen in the lungs of world war
one soldiers
who inhaled mustard gas are you kidding
me
well so that specific injury has been
linked to vaping
thc fluid so that's not linked to
to vaping nicotine fluid that's from
vaping
black market thc fluid that was cut with
uh vitamin e acetate yeah still however
baby nicotine does affect youths lungs
it causes
breathing problems i in my own research
i hear a lot about raising
excuse me wheezing and a hard time
breathing and coughing and the youth
that i talk to really
cite that they're having a hard time
performing and things like sports
they're having a hard time singing and
they are feeling like it wasn't worth it
for them to start it in the first place
a lot of them are dependent on nicotine
now they don't feel good
without vaping so that's why we have
these two different programs we have uh
behind the haze which is a commercial
and website that specifically speaks to
teens and then let's talk
vaping which is a website that is
trying to give tools to parents to talk
to their kids about vaping
absolutely let's talk vaping.com parents
check it out please
find out the details about this because
again as i was reading through it was
just disgusting to me
how these kids are taking up this
horrible habit and
as far as i'm concerned it's just as bad
as smoking i i've seen the effects of it
and it is not good
dr pearson thank you so much i
appreciate your time
thank you for having me absolutely all
right folks and don't forget join me on
the mlj show facebook live tonight
at 7 p.m where we'll have the recap of
the interview parents we got to get on
it because our kids are picking up some
bad habits